How you doing good people and everyone this
is the Ruben report we have a TYT
all star panel Ben Mankiewicz
Jimmy Dore I think you know these guys
so let get right to a Jimmy I appreciate
the way up to the people
they play like that people like to
delineate between anyone to give a wave
or any sort of acknowledgment
I and every I die I would like you to
take the one shot today
for a quick second because I do like rub
Rep hacer like a better show
yeah that the after hour day oh yeah
will do that how we finish up a handbag
any
Google okay I like what I see that show
you're gonna be on that show
I have the rub rub the average though it
was interviewed by Brian Williams for
them
NBC Nightly News and he later couple
bombs I mean huge breaking news
we've got to quit so realistic livers I
was trained as a spy and sort of the
traditional sense of the word in that
I we have to work undercover overseas
pretending to work in a job that I'm not
I
and even being assigned a name that was
not mine I'm
but I am a technical specialists I'm a
technical expert
I don't work with people I don't work
room
agents what I do is I put systems to
work
for the United States I and I've done
that at all levels
from from the bottom on the ground all
the way to the top II
okay that seems pretty huge nobody knew
about this even President Obama saying
he was a low-level
systems analyst or a low-level hacker
everyone in the government
has been saying that whereas you can
hear more about this but
this is human trait I don't know I don't
know that it's huge it's
interesting and the debate about who
eric's
ago Eric snowden that is that the picnic
well yesterday
Edward Edward she's I'm like why I my
that a debate about Edwards snowden
interesting
like and I like talking about it but
it's not really important
like it still only matters what you
really
still only matters what he released
and and you know at and what we're gonna
do about it like to end the debate that
comes afterwards like
import the administration tries to
minimize it but doesn't really it
doesn't really
surprise me you know and it does it
again suppose that we find out that
that he should have been their argument
could quickly change
quickly shift from he's not high enough
ranking
to know better to now they could go he
should have known better
yeah but you know so I mean I'll at that
that's why I don't
it's interesting it's it's great we
interesting that are either really
changes with the most important
discussions about this RB yeah with what
you said that he dropped to
big bombs like dogs eat a lot a
Salvadorian food but the
that that wasn't the case and I like it
Brian Williams given us a serious face
with a retired
but then he had to take it into a
follow-up is it a copy at an improv
class over the UC be
he had to get to right away people are
commonly yeah what we talk about
snowed in gyros by are you surprised a
yes I because we've been to again what
what what we've been told is that this
guy's a low-level him
than and I always said we'll a piece on
the low block me as access all this
unbelievable information it turns out
he's a brilliant spy
and you said but doesn't that make Obama
look bad breath
writes a book which I was saying well
then how did they let Obama keep going
out there and keep saying he's a low
level because that's what they do they
discredit
so whoever is bomb blows the gives out
information
that they don't want to give out they
discredit him just like they did with
Valerie Plame and her husband
when he discredited FAA so it's just the
conspiracies happen right out in the
open and then when someone says hey this
is a good thing that's happening
they discredit him and that's exactly
what he saying that they've been doing
to do you think Obama new and then yes
you think someone I see anat wait until
we get some
look there's gonna the the government
were gonna the United States gonna say
something
different about what is level spying was
why I my hunch is that there is probably
away
you can had his if you to believe is a
low level position
you actually described look is a low
level position who
if it is a low level position who
installed systems
for the National Security Administration
to keep our secret safe like
it's not like a low-level employees at
the Young Turks I mean I could so
graduates the janitor this great little
stop was still pretty
right so even like my there may not even
be a different
in in our gym what he did it just
characterizing it like
the NSA might say with they were is
thirty-seven people to report to you
before he got to the other the NSA an
ego I was essentially spy
that's why like II I already see it
conversation devolving nationally about
this that then I wouldn't be that
interested
like I'm interested in his politics and
what motivated him in
is he gonna get prosecuted like that
stuff interest me again not a bit as
important as
a that what you released and how we
react to that
as a country director as you're both
saying of course the government is going
to look to
discredit him and he addressed that now
the camera
mind the 90s think they might freemen in
certain ways and say all you know he's a
low-level analyst
but what they're trying to do is they're
trying to use
one position that iPad and a career here
where their
to distract from the totality of my
experience which is that
I've worked for the central intelligence
agency undercover
overseas I've worked for the National
Security Agency
undercover overseas and I'm work for the
defense
intelligence agency has a lecture at the
joint counterintelligence training
academy
where I developed sources and methods
for keeping our information people
secure
in the most hardstyle in dangerous
environments around the world
so when they say I'm a little Systems
Administrator that I don't know what I'm
talking about
I'd say it's somewhat misleading I'm
obviously very pro snowden improve the
release of the second period thing
slightly cryptic about him right maybe
that just comes with the job you know
I was watchin the see where we watched
it together CNN's
take on that they ran that play out in
the CNN anchor I can identify
body could play anchorman on virtually
any television girl very professional
very professional afterwards he said
quote a lot of energy is put me into
giving a sense of importance to its
position
CNN will take a stand on climate change
I
writing me they can literally bring
someone on the network who will deny a
that evolution
exists but they'll take a shot it snowed
in at the first opportunity
but so I think you will that see a lot
of that
that said he was really into giving
themselves as report
that but if you were being minimized by
other people your natural
any persons that a response would be to
say normal you're right
eurozone right we can't get too caught
up in the the new ones every little
thing he says and how he says it cuz
that's not what this is really about
yet so I think that if your CNN
going back to your point if you're going
to try and discredit Edward snowed in
you have to do with backs like oh yeah
he said he was a spy turns out he was
right
turns out he said he said he worked
overseas doing this he did it you can
just go
while he's putting a lot a review the
dry and wet bag is important well let me
say what he said was with Paul scored a
quiet
it was true everything he said he was
well that's what bullshit about
that CNN what about the other thing was
total bullshit it was a weird better
editorializing and there's only one
response to this is you call
the DIA in the CIA and the NSA and you
say what was a job and they go
we're not telling you and then you say
by the way we call these people to see
their ass dog was telling the truth
and they wouldn't comment right to
remove an actual good story I'm gonna
get CNN will be there but somebody might
do that to my final thought is
you think these guys ever stepping foot
the US again no
is there any chance that Lena maybe
jimmy carter's president again
I guess that put a UI I look I'm gonna
just said II there's a scenario where he
set foot in the US
and he spends a little bit I'm in jail
on
that worked out and that's what I do
that's how I'd handle I put him in jail
I they've been consistent and that I
wouldn't put in I would throw away I'll
is that he got a traitor you like but
but you know some other things he gave
up
were things that he should be given up
because he gave up so much tougher
turned out there was some stuff in the
probably shoulda got
the NSA stuff is incredibly important
that we all know like it but the guy in
jail for three years tweeted
write down every bit a federally by he
brought a book you get
gazillionaire after right however
everybody wins sometimes we just deal
with their cell you know about the way
to Afghanistan the other day and we
accidentally outed wanna borrow inspired
by putting them on a list the people
that run show up at Obama's event so we
do it
whether snowed in doing this or nitro by
the way goes on Fox News and compares it
to Valerie Plame's is worth about
pleaded
intentionally and then lied about it on
a regular basis if you're watching this
video is loading slowly and you're in
the United States there is a reason why
the United States is now ranked
thirty-year in broadband speed
and that we pay more than many other
West United Nations we've got some info
for you
so US download speeds right behind
Iceland Romania Bulgaria France Russia
the UK and many more
we also pay more an average a fifty-five
dollars a month for broadband service
while countries with faster connections
like someone they just mentioned
come in at about forty-five dollars a
month a Hong Kong which has the fastest
internet speeds in the world
they pay about 40 percent less than we
pay
about 31 bucks a month I am I guess this
shouldn't surprise us because it seems
like most the bar
stop in the United States is not working
that well our infrastructure
now our broadband arm is it weird that
we're not talking about
this more that this that because
everything's online
the computer it's all online should we
be more concerned about our slow ass
internet what struck me is what I'm
curious about really after reading that
article was
how many of those countries how much
government investment
but obviously look I get the government
invested a lot in the Internet to be at
work
but to keep those speeds up to date like
is it all
the business is just do it themselves is
that they're motivation
or is there get is that government work
to make sure because there is a vested
interest
for business purposes for every purpose
that were government
newburgh the government use a press
release guys get subsidies from the
government
yeah I would imagine the they do and
we're leaving it up
pretty much to near as I can tell have
all the information here but we're
leaving it up Comcast try to merge with
time-warner
which will have so many customers it a
lot
there's no incentive for them updated
and make sure that move into the top
five or top 10
because when you have how many customers
they're about to have
120 million whatever is a great mergers
allowed to go through
though control half the country's yet
high-speed internet in the bill were
with me they're all pain fifty-five
dollars a month we literally
we can't we don't know what to do with
all this money writes a plate only
getting worse the Time Warner Comcast
thing is only gonna make this worse than
what was the one this week DirecTV and
AT&T
so that even try to manipulate make that
happen going on that matter so
it's only going to get worse because
they have no interest because there's
so little competition well I think teddy
roosevelt taught us that
a huge monopolies are a good thing to
get they help their economy they help
beer
they help the general public everybody
gets the get a piece of the pie
yeah 11 person owns everything yeah in
that about we were gassed up calling a
broadband is 2014 to woman band its okay
I know why I we keep doing that sorry
sorry I don't know why
go yet with wire so the the last merger
that they didn't approve
the federal government was way and a
was its not sprint but the what's the
other 11 to be taken over by any way
they did not let one of those murders go
by which I couldn't believe you never
because one obviously here here's a tip:
if the merger it doesn't benefit to
consumers are not supposed to let it
happen at 11 merger happen with it said
it to benefits the company but not the
consumers and that's what happened so
we're gonna get less choice right when
this merger happens
wearing it less choice when I get poor
service already at higher prices
yet they're gonna let this go through
because we live in a banana republic
not technically banana but I like to
misuse that term
me corrupt you're close enough what
happened to USA number one
are we number one in anything anywhere
we number one then a right now me we
said above me said
we are number one in bankruptcies
attributed to medical care
we're number one I think industrialized
world and infant mortality
so we we've got a lot number ones so
we've got a couple this with another one
to God s
number one yet and that's what a lot of
those number one but back in the day and
those things were
where there any that really I guess at
one point we must have had the number
was certainly a growing economy in the
world someone growing guy in the world
and
you know where we're number one in war a
you know they say about the Washington
Senators before they left
you know what Washington was first in
war first in peace
last in the American League and but now
we're
not even not even first and be
no one no one would know it would no one
would right argue that with a straight
face
I i worry about like that did something
like the Internet the way
that the again it just feels like that
the this
us maintaining elite internet speeds and
status
like that requires government
intervention somehow I'm not saying they
have to pay to but then they have to
subsidize it they have to spur
well they would have to tell Comcast me
you have to up
we're gonna allow this were here here a
deal by
2022 were sixth in the world
make that happen whatever it is get the
speed up to whatever it needs to be
yeah does the government in a weird way
have a vested interest in our internet
not being met good
no I by that we can add we want to
access the information is easily
well i think i hula hoop benefit so what
what I think should be happening
is that the municipality should be
making internet available to everyone
for free
right because they done studies and they
figured out that the places that do that
actually helps everyone's business
a with your able to access the air wifi
no matter where you are inside the city
it their business goes up productivity
goes up tax revenue goes up
so it pays for itself it's one of those
things that helps people get kids get
educated kids can get on the internet
whatever they want
at school at home on the bus no matter
what so this is it so they could have
wifi so that's what we of course that's
what we should be doing
just like pat health universal health
care what you have universal white by
an Internet access because that helps
everybody in rises or everyone because
we won't
because there's money in a select few
people in keeping it the way it is
so speakers select few people so we done
every week news stories on net
neutrality so net neutrality got flipped
it was by an FCC appointed guy that was
an Obama campaign bundler
who also worked in the telecom lobby is
at the telecom lobbyist
so between this story and net neutrality
is the Internet as we know it really on
shaky ground right now
like arian our last are sort of
Chrissy's on shaky ground right now
was we don't we don't really live in and
baca see that's what where our leaders
are responsive to
the there are people that they are
boating from the voters are only
responsible to the dollar class we say
all the time
and you know what happens when you look
at the gun control right we talk about
all ninety percent of the people want a
background check
we didn't get it what do you call that
what kinda government do we have this is
in a democracy anymore
this is government by the few for the
few one of the few
bring us home I was pretty effective
bring it home I don't think
the you know with the let's let's wrote
let's bring it
let's take a nice brought finish in make
it much narrower that's what we like to
do
well television a holiday sorry but you
know the net neutrality debate is not
over
that's the good as it were to keep
talking about are not say that we should
be dismissed
but the the FCC commissioners
seem open to at the to worry that public
debate period
to hearing about too short a period and
so I'll I'm pointlessly
I'm always a little optimistic and I
think that's ridiculous but hit not be
there
I stay that way it not signed and sealed
yet and part of that is that we
talk about it and say that the the needs
to be preserved
all right there you go let's talk about
old people in fact that makes everybody
happy we're dedicating
the segment Blanche Devereaux by the way
all people are getting more F TD's
then ever we've got proof
between 2011 and 2012 FBI
sexually transmitted infection increased
by 3 percent for those between 45 and 65
and seven percent for those over 60
when it comes to forgetting about safe
sex we always think the vulnerability of
young people but there's the Fifty
Shades of Grey effect were older people
are being more
explorative but not necessarily
remembering to use a condom in that from
doctor Jones is the chairwoman
a British Medical Association's GP
committee so yeah go
that personal a
David pointed out that STI has more
politically correct that std's
who was making that argument haa what
the
Ikea gonorrhea is always been super
uppity about that
gotten you know going to a beard things
that is what we call the Wreckers wasn't
what which one was the clap
a guy with gonorrhea would you rather
have a disease or infection
right that today there are no lol I'd
rather have infection that it is and I
think I'd rather
I think I'd rather have a disease and
infection can give you sepsis I'm I
I'm afraid of sepsis your fears that I
for such as hell
I accept this is what it is infection
goes horribly Corrado
you know what FDA you don't die you need
to watch warehouse are
result that the hope that the yet there
yet all people having more sex and then
look they worried play all easy on the
old people order all rights are you
human 45 to 65
they still yes X yeah are you guys in
the the 45
you know when I get there though and I
predicts
liar what yet well now they have by Agra
too so I think that probably has a lot
to do with it breaks in between by Agra
and then what they're calling the Fifty
Shades of Grey effect that
older people are being more sexually
expressive
assuming that these are like threatening
conditions so lately about
obviously but I mean yeah a
three-percent increase in Tom a7 percent
increase in others
might not be worth it I mean it might be
worth it do not use a condom
yeah like that like buying we always I
don't expect the
week at all except that edit their
expert I figured that this was really a
polite way of saying look how many
people in their fifties are now having
anal sex
like but they did what they aren't
specific help to like who
you know better follow-up study that
they didn't put publish online
why do we get so weird about older
people and sex can work
older people altered all I am worried
but we think the people having sex
they're good people in their twenties
pretty much a writer I gotta be another
are there was a point appears that your
in your porn viewing
yeah but your younger man Jimmy tire
basically the same generation there was
a moment
it happen on television and it happened
in shortfall
fantasy were all the sudden like the
women I was interested and we're all
38 years old yes just like that all of a
sudden it went from
I see a gorgeous 22-year-old and I think
she should be addressing
a right at and now what's up show when
there's a beautiful blonde 41-year-old
on television
had nice back at really good at I'm the
same way they say that a lot
who men are attracted to you has a lot
to do with how older mother was when
they were young
so I was born late my mother's life so
I'm more attracted to women who may be
over 40 years old
me too I was 42 it that is literally the
most depressing thing I've heard
months you to make not only makes a
great for me because I'm married now
and I've been with my wife for fourteen
years and I'm more attracted to her now
than when we first started dating
so working out for me know I'll or gets
depressing that you will get what they
get too if you wanna fuck your mom
are at the end of the day this is about
talking about it dollars's
it why I think about they say when
you're in bed though it's not just you
and your partners to you and your
partner to other people up or the people
her parents and your parents are all in
bed together and that there are chemical
mingling
right to my I'm a loner what Israel
you are struck freudian a min is it too
late to teach
older people as or what we call them out
on people
people people these people have a higher
age it too late to teach them all the
same sex tricks because they didn't grow
up with that with
the sex ed we think that there in the
day the having sex with older person
it's like rain will they stop to yell
get off my mock
you know I mean it's up gotta get up
while on but I just wanna tell that joke
gag order as good
experts play yet I picked up some early
hominin get it but there are a lot more
of it
much at Latino I was using it in loooove
Balonne bad I people I don't you yell
that you are yet you wanna piss off an
old person
walking along are part of our house not
it probably is
a little tougher to observe dry those
points on but again a bit we're not
seeing
about minimizing my cuz I am but a
couple that guy clomidia
you know like doing that is what
penicillins that you completely by it
yeah I think the Cure with a and about
it what are we talking about
yeah if there are you guys having sex in
your seventies and eighties
I hope so I certainly hope so with each
other with the air
that's where it's gonna go that way this
is all leaving the sexual tension
between you do today
I don't think you do experiment the
older I get II
my desire for sex it's just my ability
right I'm tired I get you know all that
stuff gotta
boner pill what have you and so I think
I'll always wanna have sex is just lay a
buddy just other things get there was
like the
my back hip maybe if I stretched and
have a coffee you have a headache
right or I could just stay here and be
totally sedentary
like that all year at a very attractive
option
alright well let's go from sex to
republican
the this is actually pretty good the AP
is running a story right now about how
the younger generation up republicans
are down with the gays and they are down
with we need and they give us a couple
examples
a college republican group leader in
Alabama with nearly kicked at the party
for supporting gay marriage so that
means a leader with down with gay
marriage that something
the successful push to legalize gay
marriage in Minnesota was backed by
several prominent younger republicans
in colorado the spokesman for a group
that push to legalize marijuana
was a republican activist who is just a
couple at the total things but there is
definitely a sense
then on the social issues mainly gay
marriage and
marijuana that the republicans are
slowly coming along
this is good news am i right humidor
well this is the way it's always been
right the republicans the conservatives
are always late to the party so I
understand how we still give any other
ideas any credence
ever so they've been bitching about gays
for ever
and whatnot they're gonna stop slowly
and soul but their next thing and then a
marijuana so they're gonna stop bitching
about marijuana and then they're gonna
finally come around to climate change
when they're all underwater not gonna
come around her
you know so just like what else are you
got a course you guys are wrong you been
wrong about everything what haven't you
been wrong about
you're wrong about civil rights to i
mean you're wrong about the EPA
you're wrong about fucking every hour
energy policy
you're wrong about suppressing the vote
what aren't the wrong about so what
you're young person what is it that
attractive about the Republican Party in
those stories what's great is your right
about everything whether this is not one
thing
that they're right about that one nor
yet they still continue
to manage to convince young people that
they're better on the
economy that generic term for the
economy
when we know full well that that is not
the only actress is not true it
your I'll so I don't you know it's it's
frustrating and what it all
a lot of what it gets 22 is what they'll
never come around on as you know
suppressing the vote the and separate
packages they still like goodgreat other
more open a black
me the mall immigration right before but
it did the people look different
they're still there still not on board
with that but they're good that's gonna
go away to after date lose again in 2016
they will then become the party that's
gonna try and embrace hispanics and an
immigrant they're gonna become the party
that matter
that matter at the end of the day if
they do it for principle or for doubted
not tired out doesn't matter of great
things better down the road yet
here's why don't think they'll do it
because as long as with what they
if you think that I'm being too harsh
about race and that there are plenty of
young republicans
are racist some of them don't know yet
like with their in bed with
you like real on but where they'll never
come around where the part where there
are always going to get
resistance at the top of the party is on
well
they don't like poor people and they
never will and so when you when there's
this
thought that republicans after 2016 will
cover out on immigration reform
was people earning those people are
still poor and may install the
government assistance
you know what any party that that is
going to be a very tough reconcile for
the I think
and in that story by the way you see
that like
the that that in that list that you gave
that young Republican Alabama
she was still nearly together the party
that was a woman
but but the head of the republican party
Alabama was still like you know
that was very bad you know he was like
that we didn't like that that was
incongruous it didn't work so
I mean like those are anecdotal stories
and I mean they're movement its
incremental they've moved the ball from
the half yard line
to the three-quarters of the 1-yard line
to me they have ninety-nine years in
like 10
love them really helps move them yeah
doesn't I think we can live jeb bush I
think if jeb Bush's the nominee that
there they
he's gonna change the party about
immigration per share for ever gotten a
lot immigrants they are at you in your
room his brother was a
compassionate conservative he added me
take up until he loves immigrants yes so
if that is okay but now
well yes of course you know and he has
the he has the
the Colombian part of his fam will
happen families made a call me
they said the people who come harry said
that they're doing at the moral act for
trying to help their family
there being more of that we're supposed
to do they want to come here and working
up the family
and we should try to help them instead
of trying to shed on that thing to say
that the cold calculated political movie
not something he necessarily
I think its bowl but it's going to
require money it's gonna require these
people are poor
many of them are dirt-poor and I think
that's going to be a very tough sell
a very tough sell for republicans who
that is that is
at that a call to who they are helping
other people yes really help they don't
wanna with people who don't need
picked it right back wait to get back to
to weeding gay marriage or so
do you guys think this is just gonna be
a state by state thing for both of them
or is there any point the federal
government got a job at well
because they're especially gay marriage
I mean it's just every week it's another
one we've seen it yet luck there the
a venture that look realism will take
over and they're important issues are
making sure
that the people who are gonna vote for
Democrats can't vote for Democrat yes
that job one for them game your like the
pope
like there's a degree oven you see some
Republican attorneys general around the
country
realizing I'm not gonna fight anymore
this is a silly thing
this is a silly effort to be fighting on
on gay marriage like we're gonna lose
edits done and sadly as the pope said
hey look I i'm against abortion and I'm
anti
a gay marriage but I'm Nottage talk yet
what the hell back she said was if
someone wants to invite me to a disco
party slam home I to condemn the head
redacted redacted up should the Tea
Party in the libertarians
so the Ronde the Rand Paul's shouldn't
they be four
legalization of weed and for gay
marriage they were if they were
Ron Paul what they are Barack right by
Rampaul is not for
gay marriage as far as I know it really
sort of weird about we do
but he wants you to have individual
liberty and individual rights in this
wheelhouse stuff if they were being
intellectually honest well
yet he talked up 0.8 Rampal Rand Paul is
trying to play a delicate game where he
can be you right wing enough to get the
nomination
and the ill for him it'll be that a
fairly easy track to the center yet we
know
like ices we presume about Rampal
is care about gay marriage a doesn't
care about weed those are
that important or right being a republic
what he doesn't want to deal with fall
into the trap
love being his father who appeals to
a bientot kids in college but when it
really gets serious that he's
marginalized in seeing he
he needs to be seen as look at me I'm
one of those tablets mint
but I'm still have this little cocoon
Brevard outta at the bear
it would be very hard for so we're
agreed though in theory that I read a
bleed on
that's gonna help here rare it
ultimately gonna play but if they don't
remember he's also a club
the CAF president yeah exactly 0 but in
theory they should be four gay marriage
and legalization of weed Ray Bradbury
for terry they should be but is there a
libertarian that is should although
should also be right yet but where are
those guys
well I mean economic I guess
conservatives do with social
conservatives
should run i know i mean Georgia you
need to articulate what they should get
there
being true to their idea yes it be able
to order established that the country is
to follow
but the Conservatives correct me if I'm
wrong you know their district
constructionist with the government with
the cunt constitution so they would say
less government
and you don't be a the same the
Constitution you can regulate
my marijuana or my marriage so you can
get to do that i think thats what a real
conservative
would say the real conservative would
say I'm not for abortion but i'm for the
government's they not a bit
right or not that's the difference
really don't but I don't think I would
estimate because there's a marriage if
those strict constructionist and
religious conservatives
rack yes the issue so final thought on
this which goes right to that
is abortion X for them after these two
things are searching every there any
chance that they'll see that he leaves
changing
and and that the huge numbers that some
order to stop biting it
the stops biting are the greatest ever
other huge I think it's something it's
closer to like sixty percent healthy
exchange
what you know but more so will always
stay the same right that I'll always be
an issue for them because
decides not to move forward is that it's
always the same thing either you think
it's a baby or you don't and so they can
always
tug at your heart strings and get you to
feel that way so that's why this
won't change I i think but everything
else is changing their abortion is a
much more intellectually
to get to is a much more intellectually
honest argument yes
but being anti-abortion a few believe
that by 2009
I think its dangers to women did not
believe that but it is more
intellectually honest
another I think juries right now I think
those numbers are basically stayed the
same
and as we saw in that story gullible
good art actually moving
on abortion their actual that that while
they're still connected to the
and really do know that God is still
anti-abortion because
if you have an abortion and have another
kid he will make it downs baby
how alright let's move on are you set up
your life well there's an app for that
there is a new app called
stranger and it lets you live through
the light I love a stranger is that
confusing let's look at a video
good
I we got a little info there but now
we've got them backstory
the app tracks your path pulling related
photos from Foursquare Google Maps along
the way
neither person if the actively do
anything I think this is the interesting
part
and no locations are ever specifically
named so anonymity is preserved at the
end of the experiment each person has
one chance to send a message to the
other either to say goodbye
or to exchange contact information so
just to be clear about what's going on
here
this is stop it all being pulled from
your phone for 20 days so you're not
actively posting to it
it's just basically watching everything
you're doing for 20 days
party things this is called hardly think
this is crazy you know we went from like
you know when Facebook started you
actually were friends with the people
that you were friends with
then you suddenly became friends with
people that we're friends with your
friends
now you're friends with people you don't
know and now you your friends are people
going to give a fuck about
so this is just the next natural step in
whatever this whole
bone is doing dollar I can't think of a
more useless
application that they are you came you
live anonymously as someone else do you
know it's like other people do past-life
regression turns out they're all kings
said same thing you know your you ever
think the other person connected to was
a fucking dock worker in Russia
yeah I may be all this there's a guy
who's unload a truck in eastern poland
let's book and see what he's doing all
day he's drinking unloading shit and
then going to bed
woohoo right let you agree but we have
such short attention spans what are the
chances anyone could follow through with
twenty days are being somebody else
people yeah it was the the jimmy sport
that was literally the worst commercial
ever seen
they were held at different times that
work that driver
yes yeah ok rate that's really all that
was walking
are it's all of it where year it's quiet
there
is in analogy I'm in a car I don't know
it's quiet
be was an elevator probably be
background musics about whoever's car is
good as well
I don't know I gotta figure this thing
out but no message but we could in this
break down walls between nations you
could see how
the israelis get the other palestinians
are living the russians could see how
the ukrainians a living make it but they
could just turn on the TV or go on the
internet or read something
this is bullshit this is on believe this
is a failure i
I give me something here this is gonna
go is is gonna be just as unpopular the
hula hoop
a.m. I'll stick April and I did pretty
well here
I think that the the the beauty in it
would be in the specificity and their
bragging about the lack especially
like and got bar yet what but I take
naked pictures of the budget black all
your face right now I'll be out for
that's the way the person but
a1 other person for 20 days you're
supposed to go you
don't have anything going on in your
life I don't have enough time to get to
the
people are already but no to return the
emails negatively track and someone you
don't even know was probably boring
that's why they signed up for this thing
yeah I think interesting people do this
this'll fail and then that all the six
weeks into its failure they'll be like
that we put a dick pic component
big yeah or get booked for three billion
bucks in there yes but there's nothing
with those those
there's a grinder and tender and all
that shit i mean that that that's gonna
are you kidding me added I you very
optimistic
it's really about derriere to be like I
don't be both got more work to get the
paper you like okay
yeah okay what while I'm at a security
checkpoint they're playing Tetris a
tractor
well I thought maybe there was something
here but maybe
maybe this is because I'm a little
younger than you getting that were
happening here well look you were making
SodaStream bottles and then get healthy
with rubber bullets
a alright if not gonna create and I
cried okay kill me
well I'll let you about it everything
decided by Eugene
the more and more studies are coming now
proving that the case
Esther either a more and we're talking
about my job as a projected
it is really good there the other being
a couch potato could actually be part of
your genetic makeup yeah it seems like
everything
is decided by our genetic make up these
days researchers at Aberdeen University
work with colleagues and China and they
did a study with
ASAP science and they found out and
that's pretty much the case
but they look sign to studying myself an
interesting genetic connection
after separating mice into two groups
those that chose to run on there will
more often and those that decided not to
run as much
the difference was clear in their
offspring after ten generations
the running mice were run on their real
75 percent more often than the other
group
and by 16 generations they were running
seven miles a day
as opposed to the average for miles seen
their motivation for physical activity
with genetic alright is everything
genetic
we like to think that it's not we
control our they in our destiny but at
the end of the day
is the primordial who's controlling
everything we're doing did you guys
react to this video the same way I did
which was like
mice runs seven-mile yeah I think like a
lot
insists that the latter on it but I mean
the Cape think up a tiny little less
I was unbelievable I'm so I was a
question about but i wanna lose
at the conclusion that would be the
equivalent how many miles for human
would be seven mother about 10,000 we
could not be rather busy
me that's what they're doing they don't
have a lot else to do yet they're not
working
we're still very babbling about god
knows what theyre they're out there like
protease
less like that was mean to me being a
morning person and a night person right
so that that maybe that like that I'm a
night person tolley I kick it somewhere
around
in night I get a little energy in me in
create they say mostly creativity
happens at night
for I was reading thing and that gives a
shit that calm and
at but that yeah I i adeptly think that
it's in your makeup BC
back families you know yeah it's it's
it's it is genetic I think and
so how much do you guys think we control
how much do you think is actually we are
and where they're using it
less than you think because I read all
these books on about
our attraction to to each other explicit
sexual attraction
and 99 percent if it is unconscious you
think you're making a choice you think
Oh I like this and that you don't fuckin
know what you like
because it's all happening unconsciously
bike they realize that meant that the
hip to waist ratio that makes a woman
attractive to men are not not absence
batter skinny or whatever
it's all these weird things that go into
it so that some sane
it more than you think your gender your
controlled genetically
later that video there's a great thing
about the the the couch potato gene
literally that your that there is a gene
that your left you're more likely to
stage that they're not just that you
generationally learn to work out but
there's something in you that makes you
want to stay
and set you up to overcome that I mean I
I literally feel like I have it is a
very hard for me to motivate
in a way that i think is beyond the
normal
human characteristic of what he said
around like I I have worked out in four
years
and now I can put the blame my parents
this is fantastic that
would like you have to have been a pro
this order the at the be the three
others bony at the end like a bit a lot
of this is by men on so you have to
overcome that
yeah I'll and but I need a pill to
overcome that right so you couldn't do
it that's at the bar that I find
fascinating that the part that you want
to sit there and I'm with you I could
watch basketball all day on a sunday and
not move
but at the same point I could go to the
gym and run around and be right but this
is heavy but you don't have that I don't
think I can overcome it
and I get now that thing that we saw in
the first part I don't get
this rush from work it out I don't I
like I get a rush from competition
I'll try and win things or lose things
but I like to be involved in some ways
course cap but I don't get like when I
run
I'll come back I'm not like all May and
water rushing with a left I don't have
that at all
got a competitive merit on a more
competitive sleeper that's right
writer I want to be like an Olympic
sleep that might get a pillowtop be
guided to jump into that you gotta have
some disparity
whether I you able to overcome your your
genetic predispositions I really know I
can't say I I got a call
I got a challenge the veracity a ban
statement that he has worked on for you
to tell me that you haven't lifted
get that much I as a belated so
heck really that's natural yeah it hard
to believe but no drug deal drugs
you know you're not using nope nope not
at all juicing and not working out which
is an odd thing to do. I am
I've never you know I was always that
active guy worked out all the time so
I don't anymore but that has to do with
Mike I
yep definitely abt only you more control
that's why
you know they say the journey of life is
to be coming just aware becoming awake
because we walk to like to sleep
tried over the years like we learned
that exertion any eggs are good
there right right turns out they're good
it you know for years in the seventies
they don't donate
you know too much red meat and now maybe
with maybe maybe it's okay certainly for
certain people and protein is definitely
good
and so this bill Richard drugs are good
or drugs are bad coffee turned out good
like you know a point great really good
for you know so but one thing that has
never changed my doctor said it's only
if you put in this project perspective
he's like
exercise they knew it then they know it
now
it helps by add years to your life you
know I have a daughter
I want to stay healthy and I had the
sense that even that
is not going to do it for me that's and
I think that there's a predisposition
not a crazy person don't you give a
sport you enjoy deeply battle all the
way back while applying softball I love
playing things to keep score
it's just hard to get older hard to find
yes six other guys to get together give
you are playing baseball so much that he
wait he plays every Sunday
I've played for a year and happen every
Sunday never been there
I got injured like three years ago when
I had only bettered why I injury I gotta
injury took me out so you have my
backside on play more but
I'd like to I miss it I'm better than
you guys I bet no
get up of your fat ass do some exercise
you can watch this while you're on the
treadmill that's where I do most my
internet Inc
a band jamie thank you guys and we will
do this again
next week bob